I'll add the motion subject to approval
the part of this annual plan process
secondly I'd like to amend the
recommendations
and the council note that cheers to the
new committees will need to be appointed
I'm a men to read
councilor Phillips to be appointed as
chair of assets and infrastructure
committee
councilor R mcphail to be appointed as
chair of order and risk councilor Reed
to be appointed as chair of community
and wellbeing committee and councilor
Dixon to be appointed as chair of policy
and planning committee now I now call
for a second are on that and then I'll
speak on the motion
uh I'm I'm unfortunately
um that's not how it works
um with those motions being null and
void
um as enacting my Powers
um there would need to be a 75
um majority um and then that would be to
call for uh that extraordinary meeting
in 21 days after those appointments that
is the process there as those motions
are no longer relevant
around the
teeth
yeah that's that's
yeah that's that's that's a that's a
that's a valid point
um that that motion there was there was
two amendments there
um the motion here that we can discuss
uh is that the council note that the
policy offers a slash policy unless
Position will need to be established to
assist with the work associated with
servicing the policy and planning
committee
um happy for that amendment to happen
um
that we're going to wait till the annual
plan until
that position is is filled is it the the
amendment there
okay do we have debate around the the
policy and planning position uh being
established
I I think I'm open to
debate around this topic about what is
best to do here whether we want to have
those conversations in those committees
and then bring them to full Council for
approval or whether it's best that we
have staff assist with this process
uh Council Reed I think given that all
councilors are on those committees we
should all have a say in that and
there's terms of reference and I'd like
to see them walk back to council and
along with staff and pot as well
because we've
value their advice
counselor Val I'm wondering if the chief
executive could prepare for us a
template for the Committees to have a
look at of the common features in terms
of terms of reference and the
opportunity then for counselors to add
to that that picks up the particular
Bend and each other committees
Council hosted
yeah just Mr me just picking up a
comment you mate should we involve staff
absolutely there is no way forward as a
council without staff involvement so
that has to be a principle of any go
forward position
yeah I agree with that Council heisted
councilor uh McDonald
when they bring the them forward because
they also bring the terms of reference
that we had for last time as well just
as a guide so that we're not not
Reinventing the wheel we just need to
run through those and just check them
off because it seemed to work on the
committee so I wasn't last time we
didn't seem to have too many problems so
let's try and stick to the same things
and save you some work
yeah you worship um just to answer that
I think that's uh certainly a
meritorious Point raised by a counselor
McDonald
um that for those committees that are
continuing in some form or other but
obviously policy and planning is a new
committee uh I just think in terms of
pragmatism and moving things forward
perhaps a hybrid solution for the
meeting to consider is Staff providing
draft terms of reference but liaison
with respect of chairs of each committee
to fine-tune it before then is
presidency Council for full critiquing
and approval
debate based on that motion that its
committees change to bi-monthly with a
six-month and a review in six months uh
councilor Heist did
three Mr Mayor just would like some
feedback from the chief executive
um on that particular item in terms of
meeting frequency what does that look
like for staff in terms of agenda
setting uh hitting Target setting
deadlines or is that something that
would be better
traversed in a separate report to inform
Council because I'm very reluctant to
sit here today and just on on the notion
that all staff are sitting standby ready
to service this table there's a lot of
Greater business done by the council
staff than service counselors we just
need to be mindful of that and the and
the resources that are in place now so
light some feedback on that now please
Steve
sorry sorry Steve I'm going to cut you
off the I think I think the motion was
to review to look into that bi-monthly
um it would be a bit tough putting these
guys on the spot right now I would
imagine in terms of that resourcing
issue I think it was to set a meeting
early and then have a look into the
bi-monthlies is that correct counselor
it was my intent but it wasn't the way
that I think it came out in the end so I
was wanting to have a round of committee
meetings in February where we were
considering
um the need for the bi-monthly meetings
and it may be that um uh the assets and
planning meets one month and the other
committees meet the following month and
Etc
um so
not trying to lock it in at the stage
capsules trainer
uh would it be wise to have that first
meeting in February then depending on
the outcome of those first meetings we
then look at bringing it up to that that
first council meeting as to whether we
actually then need to have a bi-monthly
so we don't we don't push
thank you for that Steve
Ted
you want to change that to the tour in
February tour in March or you want to
keep it as is what would you like to do
there um Council Haverhill and in the
spirit of flexibility I I would ask
committees meetings be held as soon as
practicable
rather than specifying February
so we are probably going to need some
more information from the governance
manager and what dates would be
um
practical
um and that would obviously need to be
tabled at that February meeting which is
which is correct so it'll be pretty
tight time frame from
um
agreeing to that to them moving that
forward but
if that's how it's going to be that's
how it's going to be
um so are you moving that motion
um yeah do we have a second
uh councilor McDonald do we have further
debate
uh Council Reed I'm just
referring back to the suggestion that
Council meetings start at five o'clock I
just
there are only two councilors that
aren't employed well retired
um and actually four o'clock is not a
bad time to start given the winter
months
um we often get out of here at 10
o'clock at night even when the four
o'clock starts sometimes at some
meetings and I'm for one
um
you know it's a struggle in the winter
time how many members of the public are
actually going to stay here or turn up
on a cold Winter's night anyway when
it's live streamed I just think that's
um a point that we need to stop and
reflect on before we start making calls
about Changing Times
the councilor read the motion on the
table is regarding that bi-monthly we
can Circle back to another motion
regarding Changing Times but thank you
for your comments
so we we're changing we're changing the
four committees timings do we have an
issue with the council meetings and
those dates or are we all located there
is that encompassed in that motion
enough
um Susan at least so cool let's move on
so the emergency committee
um
did you have any further comment on that
Susan around the emergency committee
yeah yeah yes
um
is there any questions from elected
members on yeah councilor Reed thank you
Mr Mayor I'm just wondering um given
that now it's um legal status that we
can actually have zoom meetings is this
actually necessary to have this because
all it takes is an email or a phone call
and we're all available
thank you councilor yeah I would tend to
agree
um there's also you know wording in the
ACT about calling extraordinary meetings
in emergency cases so or actually
emergency meetings I think they're
referred to
um so I'm I'm in agreement I I don't
particularly see the the necessity for
the Emergency committee but I'm I'm open
to the country from around the table if
there is any
I agree
um today's environment we have access to
electronic platforms uh if we have six
of the council get together and the
mayor that's the Quorum I think that
would be an appropriate Forum instead of
Reliance on the the mayor and two
councilors as we've done in the past
uh so with
no motion on the table I suggest that we
move on to the next agenda item
uh Council Dixon
thank you worship there's just something
that I'd I'd like to raise would it be
possible over the holidays to get
emergency numbers for social services on
our website because
um anecdotal evidence shows us that this
is a bad time for Family Violence
minister of law very much like for
example what the Ombudsman does when
when you actually put a complaint to the
ombudsman the Ombudsman has the ability
to uh strike out a complaint as being
fixatious so my view was that having
someone to assess it in a a public
administrative law context about the the
merits uh or seriousness of not the
seriousness sort of say oh I complaint
was administrative in nature and you
will see some councils have used
administrative lawyers
for the for for investigation as well so
very good question you could you could
run arguments I think either way
employment or administrative my view was
that having someone that was familiar
with the organization but sufficiently
distance was a good way to have an
assessor in place
well question for the tutors that could
have councilor right uh no just a
comment um further to councilor
stronger's comment
um that I see that the panel the
independent investigators are actually
employment lawyers so I think that sort
of negates that
thank you councilor
is there any other questions for the
chief executive
councilor maxonell
does Michael Gambit have much
interaction with the staff he is he is
he a regular lawyer we use or so he
worship yeah Michael has
um
some regular interaction with some staff
more particularly
um
myself
Matt Bayless on some of the three Waters
projects
planning staff when we have an RMA issue
but through through that process has got
to know and of course he's presented to
the council he's got to know the council
reasonably well not intimately but
reasonably and he's based in Dunedin
any further questions for the tubular
kid I think it's pretty straightforward
but with the cheer woman like to to
speak to it